نقلت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين
مصريين كبار قولهم ان اسرائيل طلبت من مصر
تركيب اجهزه استشعار على طول محور
فيلادلفيا لتنبيهه في حال حاولت حماس
اعاده بناء الانفاق بعد الحرب كما طلبت
اسرائيل من القاهره ان تزودها بتنبيهات
مباشره في حال فعلت اجهزه الاستشعار وان
تسمح لها بارسال طائرات استطلاع المسيره
الى المنطقه للتعامل مع الامر وقالت
الصحيفه ان مصر ردت على الطلب الاسرائيلي
بانها ستنظر في الامر لكن نقطه الاخطار
المباشر عند تفعيل اجهزه الاستشعار او
الموافقه على الطائرات المسيره ستكون
انتهاكا للسياده المصريه واضافت الصحيفه
نقلا عن المسؤولين المصريين قولهم ان
المفاوضات بهذا الشان تبلورت خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين لكنها عالقه
حاليا